we spent so much time in our school
system right now evaluating a valuing of
valuing
that we have no time left over to
actually activate the potential at all
it's like it's like what are we doing
here people you know
like we're we're devoting like virtually
100 of our time to be like okay
um you know uh your stuff did you learn
it here's stuff did you learn it here
exactly yeah exactly here's your test
here's your score here's your score next
here's your next score here's your next
score
it's so it's not it's i mean for these
students it's it's soul sucking right
so i want to kind of put the soul back
into or the human the huma
that might have sounded too woo-woo but
i want to put the human human back
into the education system where we treat
students as humans first and
i think that we could have
self-actualizing schools
where the schools care first and
foremost about the self-actualization of
the students
not the test scores of the students and
of course
knowledge is important i mean i'm not
trying to make this extreme argument and
say
you know no math forever i'm not saying
that don't worry you can calm down
[Music]
on today's episode of yang speaks
humanistic psychologist
scott barry kaufman joined to talk with
andrew so a lot of the ideas we ran
on for president scott has done actually
clinical research on
things like why we educate how we should
be educating human beings if we will
and why our society is not particularly
set up
for us to be successful it's a
fascinating conversation
you're going to love it and also just
importantly want to let you guys
know every thursday we're back with more
yang speaks episodes and we're doing
a series on the future of we've done the
future of money we've done the future of
energy we're gonna do the future of
space we're gonna do the future of
cloning we're gonna do crazy stuff so
make sure you're tuning in
on thursdays as well because thursday
episodes are back
but right now scott barry kaufman
humanistic psychologist talks with
andrew yang
on yank speaks
[Music]
it is my pleasure and privilege i've
been looking forward to this ever since
uh
uh he and i connected to welcome to yang
speaks
psychologist author
actualizer of human potential pretty
much everyone who wants good things
in their lives should be listening to
this man
scott barry kaufman scott welcome to the
to the podcast what a dream this
come true this is for me i've wanted to
talk to you for a long time it's such a
pleasure to be here
well i felt the same way uh you're such
an incredible thinker
and your work is so up my alley
it's it's pretty wild likewise it's
bi-directional
yeah i agree i feel like both of us have
been approaching some of the same
problems from kind of different angles
but would love for you to introduce
yourself so that people can get a sense
of
your background you have a phd in
cognitive psychology from yale you
studied
uh in the uk um i think you have like a
bs and also cognitive science from
carnegie mellon
or one of these other very very frankly
like esteemed institutions
um but tell us a little bit more about
yourself like how you arrived at that
point and how you became passionate
about
uh studying how people frankly can be
like happier healthier stronger
sure yeah so yeah i'm a humanistic
psychologist and i
have a training in cognitive science but
i'm really interested in understanding
what it means to be human what it means
to be a vital human to live a life of
meaning and purpose and creativity
and i really got interest in this topic
as a young kid
when i was put in special education for
a learning disability that i had
and i felt as though the kids that were
in the classroom with me in the special
ed classroom were capable of so much
greater things than anyone gave them
credit for
and do you have a sense as to why they
um put you there or identified you that
way
yeah well i had an auditory uh
processing disability
um that just made it uh hard i had a lot
of food in my ears so just made it hard
for me to process things in real time
i have a friend who had a son who had
that issue
and then you know like his teachers
categorized him as like
um you know like having a learning issue
and really you just couldn't hear
stuff i mean that's all it was yeah and
they took that extra couple milliseconds
as some sort of indication that i was
stupid and
uh not only that but i was also like i
definitely wasn't oddball in terms of my
creativity and my imagination like when
all the other kids were sitting in the
circle listening to the
teacher read a story i was running
around in my superman cape so there
definitely were
i didn't know what to do with me for
sure but um
i was put in special ed and i just i
remember even at a very young age that i
just thinking to myself
you know there's got to be um a way to
show
the teachers and parents what my friends
are capable of hearing special ed i mean
they're capable of some amazing things
and then you know i got into this field
wanting to study intelligence and so
that was my entry way into the field was
the cognitive science of intelligence
and iq testing
wow this is a very fraught topic now
i mean um and you were ahead of the
curve because you've been studying this
for
decades at this point so tell us more
well so i was kept especially until
ninth grade
and i remember sitting there bored out
of my mind we're supposed to be taking
untimed
tests they would remove me from the
mainstream room history history
classroom
and put me in a special room to take an
untime test i remember thinking to
myself like
if this is untimed i have the rest of my
life to finish this test so i'm like
checked out like this is boring and a
special ed teacher took me aside who had
never seen me before
and after class she just said i think i
see you
it was like a terrifying moment i was
like what is she saying but she's like
you know i think that um you know why
are you still here you know i can tell
that you're
you're you're clearly um uh not
challenged
and it quickly turned from like why am i
here to like yeah why
am i here and i called my mom i ran to
the pay phone and i called my mom and i
said hey mom i'm not reporting back to
special ed ever again
um and she's like can we talk about this
when you get home but
um i set up a school a whole meeting
with like the school superintendent and
uh
and the psychologists and everything
because i was the first one in like war
marine
high school this you know the school
district to break out of special ed
i was the first one to come you know
this dude the student themself say you
know what i'm out of here
and they said we'll let you out on a
trial basis
which didn't feel like a great vote of
confidence they said like if you get out
and you fail all your classes you're
coming back
so i said okay well i'm going to prove
you all wrong and i and in one semester
i went from
a d remedial i wasn't supposed to ever
go to college to like straight a honor
student in one semester
yeah and then you kept putting up
straight a's i assume for a while to go
to
you know a place like except for dance
class except for dance class in college
um i got a c yeah uh well you had a
dance class at carnegie mellon which i
did not know
well well there's actually so this is
more
this is more of the story this is kind
of interesting the reason why i was in
dance classes
is because i was so determined to study
intelligence in psychology that i went
and i
auditioned for the opera program at
carnegie mellon
so i could still get into carnegie
mellon it turned out that i had some
music talent my grandfather was a
cellist with a philadelphia orchestra
and
i was taking voice lessons and i sang my
heart out and i got a scholarship to
carnegie mellon for my
opera singing and then i transferred in
through the back door to psychology
once i got there that's incredible um so
you were such a talented singer that you
could actually
get into college on that basis when did
that talent become evident after i got
out of special ed
in high school i signed up for
everything because i became i was like
what am i capable of you have to
understand andrew i had no
prior to that moment in my education
system i only viewed myself as this
disabled broken kid you know and then so
i signed up for everything i i signed up
i was like i'm gonna do west side story
i'm gonna do this and this and and i was
joking one day with my friends uh
i had a friend who was in the choir and
i was i was in there and i was joking
because i
i was like you all sound like this oh
and then the choir teacher
was like that's really freaking good
like are you an opera
like do you have training and i was like
no i'm making fun of you all
and she and so it turned out like you
know um i actually have an apparatic
voice
who knew who knew and then i started to
take some lessons and i fell in love
with like les mis and
my dream was to be javair and that was
this my audition song at carnegie mellon
was stars
from les mis what a story
um so then when you went to college on
the basis of your musical talent did you
know the entire time that you were going
to
frankly divert your energies from music
um these other pursuits or did you show
up thinking maybe i will make a thing of
this music
uh career and then go to broadway and
the rest of it was that a thought
there was a thought that if i never got
into the psychology program
that i you know i'll i'll be i'll just
be on broadway that's fine i'll settle
i'll settle for broadway
but um but what happened is i discovered
um i took a course on cognitive
psychology with anne fay
um uh at carnegie mellon and i was
reading this textbook
and and i got to this this the chapter
on intelligence
and it was howard gardner calls us a
crystallizing experience
there's this moment in your life where
you suddenly realize oh
that's what i meant to be doing on this
earth
and i looked at the front cover and it
said robert sternberg yale university
you know
who was the author of the book and in
that moment i said that's it i'm going
to study with robert sternberg
i'm going to do everything that it takes
i'm going to like be the grittiest
mother
beeper and i don't know if i can curse
on your podcast i'm going to be the
the great the greediest person you know
person
ever and i'm gonna make it into yale and
study with robert sternberg because he's
he he just he he just inspired me so
much with his thoughts about
intelligence then he had creative and
practical intelligence he said were
important in addition to analytical
intelligence and i said that's exactly
what i've been saying since i was five
years old
there are these ideas you have out there
and then when someone puts it into a
term you're like yes
and it's such a gift to the world um i i
try my best to
take advantage of that in ways big and
small whereas an example
um when i'm on a team
and then someone says like hey we should
do this particular project and i get
excited about it
my first move is to name the project
because as soon as you name something
then it becomes much more real to people
so two of the first steps i take are
number one you name it
and then number two you look at someone
and say and now you are going to be
responsible
for a project uh you know red table or
whatever it is so it's great that you
encountered that um
in professor sternberg um and then you
got hooked
and you ended up getting a phd from yale
like studying with him
yeah that's exactly right i i did a cold
email i said can i be your personal
assistant
intern for free over the summer i'll
come to yale do anything you want
um i was doing that with everyone i was
also studying i don't know if have you
ever heard of herbert simon the the
nobel prize winner
herbert herb simon he studied uh he came
up with
the idea of satisficing that most people
don't actually
choose the best decision they they're
like good enough they choose decisions
that are good enough
he's right give that man a nobel prize
exactly yeah
yeah that's what he i mean it was a
brilliant idea you know at the time
because believe it or not economists at
the time
had no i didn't didn't even didn't even
dawn on them that that's how humans
make decisions they just assumed that
the humans were maximizers
isn't that interesting no we're not
we're not maximizers we're definitely
satisfiers
i studied with her simon and uh he took
me under his wing as well and i was just
like teach me everything i just like
everyone i could find
i said teach me everything i cold caller
code emailed
the head of this cambridge university
psychology department i said can i just
like
take off a year of carnegie mellon and
go to england and you teach me
everything about iq
he was one of the leading iq researchers
and i thought that i it'd be really cool
for me to keep my own past a secret
and not tell any of these into iq
researchers about
that like their tests are what limited
me in my life but just
try to learn the truth and just try to
like just like make a contribution to
the field so they would take me
seriously someday so that i could then
change the field
but i knew that i had to learn the
classic so to speak it's a very patient
approach
scott it's a very impressive patient
determined determined
[Music]
[Applause]
all right i want to talk about debt on a
personal level i've had some debt i had
about
200 or so grand in student loan debt i
had to pay off and i got out of college
and then what happens if you have debt
is you start to get other types of debt
including credit card debt and i want to
talk to you about
upstart because upstart is a fast and
easy way
to get a personal loan to pay off your
debt all online it's like a debt
consolidator and they use a better
algorithm to figure out your actual
credit score
so if you're doing credit cards or high
interest debt or personal expenses or
student loan debt all these things
over half a million people use upstart
to get simple fixed monthly
payments which i like you put it all in
one place they find smarter rates with
trusted partners because they assess
more on your credit score because you
know and i know that you're a lot more
than just a freaking number so use a lot
of different inputs
which makes your payment determination
way more accurate so find out how
upstart can lower your monthly payments
today when you go to
upstart.com yang that's upstart.com
yang don't forget to use our url and let
them know we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com
[Music]
[Applause]
one of the very large aspects of the way
that
our kids get measured in school is
really their ability to conform to
whatever behavior is going on around
them
you know i mean like like if if you're
not sitting quietly in the circle or
you know repeating back what you need to
repeat then that's actually a very very
serious problem
um you know in a school setting and you
can easily find yourself
um put in in special ed or some other
category um
because of those kinds of issues and
then the the second thing
and this is not you but i've talked to a
lot of entrepreneurs
um and a shockingly high proportion of
them were dyslexic as kids
actually true of some entertainers too
and so
these kids are dyslexic they come in the
classroom like they have trouble
processing information the way that
other people do
teachers think that they're like
completely you know
like useless and like don't um you know
like shouldn't be anywhere near anything
um but then a lot of them wind up
finding
really creative ways to do their school
work
uh to do projects to get things done and
then a shockingly high proportion of
them wind up becoming very successful
entrepreneurs because they just apply
that to the real world
in a particular way there's something
going on with our
school system where it's rewarding a
certain degree of
behavioral conformity and a particular
form of intelligence
and then if you're uh another type of
human
um you can easily find yourself
relegated to this like oh
you know never go to college like might
as well just prepare yourself for
you know like a particular type of life
um uh kind of tracking system
that i know that i'm sure you're like
violently against given
both your experiences and your work i'm
a big advocate of gifted education you
know i'm not
anti-intelligence i'm not anti-ability
or talent but i think that we have very
misguided notions
of the different pathways that one can
achieve
giftedness and one can achieve their
ultimate dreams in their lives
we have very narrow sort of metrics and
i i've been arguing for a humanistic
education
i call it humanistic education that
treats students as human first
i i think you might might like yeah i
might recognize that my presidential
campaign slogan was humanity first
when you saw that you were like did they
take it from me acknowledgement please
yang
yeah i've been saying that for ten years
but but but but that's why i was like i
was i mean i'm so i was so on board i
don't know if you saw all my tweets i
was like oh yeah i'm going when you're
running for president
i was definitely supporting the heck out
of you but um but no i'm really all
about a
a school system that treats students not
as like what score they could appear on
a test but that views them as
the totality of who they are and
sometimes that does include intelligence
so
i'm not um i'm not one of these extreme
anti-iq kind of uh researchers i think
that
there are kids who have extraordinarily
high iqs and they're not served well by
the school system
my argument is more that no students are
being served by this
so you've now written several important
books
that each put forward very important
ideas
and i think one of your earlier books
talked about what you call the dual
process theory of human intelligence
which struck me as related to this idea
of
the fact that there are different forms
of intelligence than this kind of very
linear
academic analytic that we measure
particularly through standardized tests
and the like
and so was this your original research
was this something that you developed
uh over an extended period of time
alongside
other folks who've been looking at this
for for a while yeah
this was an insight that i had when i
was
doing my phd work i knew that i wanted
to go beyond the standard metrics of iq
but i wanted to do it in a very
systematic way that would earn me the
respect of my fellow intelligence
researchers
i didn't just want to like say you all
are stupid you know like
like the whole field sucks no i wanted
to actually do something meaningful and
when i was looking to the literature it
dawned on me that almost all these iq
tests are all at the conscious level
like conscious reasoning
and and it only and there are people who
seem to intuitively
learn things that um they were never
explicitly taught is this related to
what people call
street smart it is
yeah you know what yes absolutely um
it's it's a it's a core component
of street smarts absolutely but it's
also the core component of social skills
you know being able to like learn the
patterns of the social world but also
just like beauty nature
i mean it goes deep it's it's there's
these there are these deep
unconscious learning mechanisms that we
share with other animals
you know other animals aren't aren't
good at iq tests but they're intel they
still have an adaptive intelligence
you know we we do have these really
intelligent um
systems unconscious intuitive systems
and my question that i was curious about
is
um what is the relationship between
those who are really quick at picking
things up intuitively versus those who
are good at iq tests
and my hypothesis was that they'd be
uncorrelated now this was uh believe it
this was believe it or not this was a
controversial hypothesis because
intelligence researchers had been
studying iq for 100 years and they said
forget it you're never gonna find
anything that's not correlated with iq
we no one has ever and i said i think i
found something so okay so i created
this test
and i published this in uh our flagship
journal
called cognition where i reported a zero
correlation
between intuitive intelligence ability
and iq
ability wow i called i was so excited i
mean this was like
really exciting i was like i made a
contribution
to the field in some way i mean that's
all i wanted to do was just like to be
like considered uh
you know uh like i could make a real
intellectual
hefty contribution to the field my
father um
was a professor my grandfather was a
professor my uncle was a professor my
brother is a professor
so being a professor is kind of the
family thing
i'm kind of the academic grunt of the
litter
so so i just wanted you to know that i
understand when you say like i wanted to
make
an intellectual contribution because
when you're in that environment like you
want to put forward like a big idea or
finding that is novel and groundbreaking
it's funny though because you know when
looking back on it now it's like
i put so much work into to impress five
people like
you know like it's not like you know the
amount of people working in that really
narrow niche of the field like maybe
five you know five people that i
[Music]
impressed
all right i want to talk about debt on a
personal level i've had some debt
i had about 200 or so grand in student
loan debt i had to pay off and i got out
of college and then what happens if you
have debt is you start to get other
types of debt including credit card debt
and i want to talk to you about
upstart because upstart is a fast and
easy way
to get a personal loan to pay off your
debt all online it's like a debt
consolidator and they use a better
algorithm to figure out your actual
credit score
so if you're doing credit cards or high
interest debt or personal expenses or
student loan debt all these things
over half a million people use upstart
to get simple fixed monthly
payments which i like you put it all in
one place they find smarter rates with
trusted partners because they assess
more on your credit score because you
know and i know that you're a lot more
than just a freaking number so use a lot
of different inputs
which makes your payment determination
way more accurate so find out how
upstart can lower your monthly payments
today when you go to
upstart.com yang that's upstart.com
yang don't forget to use our url and let
them know we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com
[Music]
[Applause]
you made this this discovery
um or you you found that intuitive
learning
was uncorrelated um you know with this
other more standard
measure um and so like what that
happened then was there like this
massive
uh level of attention it opened up a
whole world for me and that world is
called creativity
so what i discovered once i discovered
what
was able to operationalize and actually
measure in a reliable and valid way this
what this intuitive intelligence kind of
ability i found
that it was predicting um forms of
creative achievement
in particularly in the arts much much
more than iq
much much more wow this is like this
sort of creative dimension
test wow or measure not test measure
yeah an indicator yeah it got the
interest of um
uh a bunch of people uh so my colin de
young was a postdoc at yale with me at
the time and
his grad student was a man called jordan
peterson
i don't know if you ever heard of that
guy yeah and so he hops on board
we get this published and this paper sho
um this follow-up paper so i had i did
that initial paper but then i did this
follow-up paper showing
um that um that if you want to predict
the arts
achievement it really is all about this
openness to experience it's all about
this
ability to um really um go
uh uh be open to your kind of
inner emotions and and appreciation of
the patterns of beauty
you know and these sorts of things and
that is that's an important skill that
we don't even we don't even like
appreciate as important at all
we definitely do not brother i mean that
that that is for sure
i was around kids um when i was young
um at these things called nerd camps
they were run by johns hopkins
so it's like the opposite extreme of
kids who frankly you know did
very well on on various standardized
tests um and then you talk about how
folks who are more intuitively um
intelligent uh maybe have degrees of
social skills or creativity or
you know let's call it like you know
judgment or problem solving things like
that
like these were the nerdiest kids ever
like and i was right there with them you
know it's like i'm not excluding myself
um but if if you were to uh put them
into put us into a situation that
required some degree of
like intuitive problem solving or social
skills or or whatnot like we would have
all been
atrocious uh like it was the most
socially awkward group of
um adolescents and pre-adolescents that
one can imagine like just straight out
of whatever stereotypical
um you know thing you you'd uh have i
mean you know back in the 80s at that
time would be like
kind of revenge of the nerds type
material um
so so there was always this feeling that
there was like some sort of
like an inverse relationship between
like a degree of book smartness
and um social skills and
um street smarts or common sense well
andrew you know i did go to carnegie
mellon
and i the one of the nerdy i mean i felt
at home
i finally felt like i came home i
actually then added i don't really i
don't think i've
ever told this on a podcast but i
actually ended up adding on a computer
science degree from there as well
before i left um i was just like i felt
so at home with the nerds
and i i mean i joined a fraternity but
it was like we're nerds in a fraternity
you know like you know so i i it was it
was a real nice feeling coming home and
and also it can be comfortable to be a
nerd and to be among your friends and
not have the pressure to have social
skills
so there's a wonderful thing about
removable of the pressure to have social
skills
yeah that that pretty much sums it up
it's true you know like uh it's
a wonderful thing so after you'd
identified this
um other measure or scale of
intuitive intelligence like i i feel
like that would have led to like a lot
of other
research a lot of um uh other folks
trying to dig in and see if there were
other qualities that they could have a
measure for is that correct
there was a turning point in my life
where i was teaching at nyu right after
i graduated and i was doing
that kind of uh research but then martin
seligman
who's the founder of the field of
positive psychology have you heard of
martin seligman
yes okay cool and i generally love
positive psychology
oh cool so he's like the founder of the
field and uh he just
put like plucks me up he's like hey
we're starting a new center
called the imagination institute here at
penn do you want to run it
and i was like um yeah so i just
quit everything i was like peace nyu you
know and i
and i and this was great because keep in
mind i was born and raised in philly so
this was a chance for me to come back
and be closer to my parents that is
pretty awesome and
so so that really you know things happen
in life that are unexpected you know you
don't expect
you know martin selig to you know be
like hey do you wanna do you wanna i
think you're the man for the job
so i ended up for three i spent four
years of my life at penn and i
studied and my whole research interest
and everything shifted so focused on
what is the human imagination and how
does that um
we were curious how that differs from
like intelligence for instance for
instance
in the brain and we published some
neuroscience studies on this but we also
funded
a lot of researchers to come up we held
a call open call for everyone in the
world
who can come up with the next
imagination test like creativity test
um you know um and so we funded like 15
projects so we also
went um and had about 10 different
domains of human endeavors we brought
like the most famous like most
imaginative people across different
fields
uh from humor to math to physics um
to a wide range of things to
spirituality um and we have these
imagination retreats where we scan their
brains
and then we try to understand what the
special sauce of creativity is
wow four years of my life four years of
my life yeah
so what do more human-centered schools
look like in practice
um have you ever come across the future
project by any chance
yes there's an educational organization
um where they put in a uh
office of a dream director in the school
system
and any student can go to the office of
dream director and say well this is my
dream this is
you know i have this idea or this this
goal like i want to end bullying i want
to
i want to make the world a better place
and the dream director is like great
let's help get you there and they help
give
mentors and resources to help them
realize their projects
this the kind of shift i want to make is
a shift from a culture of evaluation
to a culture of inspiration so that's
kind of my tagline from evaluation to
inspiration
um because we're we spent so much time
in our school system right now
evaluating a valuing of valuing that we
have no time left over
to actually activate the potential at
all it's like it's like what are we
doing here people
you know like we're devoting like
virtually 100 of our time to be like
okay
um you know uh your stuff did you learn
it here's stuff did you learn it here's
exactly yeah exactly here's your test
here's your score here's your score next
here's your next score here's your next
score
it's soul it's not it's i mean it for
these students it's it's soul sucking
right
so i want to kind of put the soul back
into or the human the huma
that might have sounded too willow but i
want to put the human human back
into the education system where we treat
students as humans first and
i think that we could have
self-actualizing schools
where the schools um uh care first and
foremost about
the self-actualization of the students
not the
test scores of the students and of
course knowledge is important i mean
i'm not trying to make this extreme
argument and say you know no math
forever
i mean i'm not saying that don't worry
you can calm down i know you like math
um i i do too well well one of the
things i just want to let you know like
you know i'm very open to the fact that
and this is data driven
um is that uh arts and drama um
really help kids right exactly
yeah like college readiness goes up
interesting college goes up
you know like like that so um you should
know i'm very very open to the fact that
um arts and creativity should be central
uh in our education particularly as most
people know like if you're concerned
that
um ai and and technology are going to do
a lot of
rote tasks and so you know trying to
teach our kids to become
better uh processors and and robots
themselves is
probably a loser
yes yes um so you know so like i'm i'm
i'm not um just like this pro math
person and on that front
[Music]
[Applause]
are you unhappy with your smile you no
longer have to because
thousands of people have used candid the
clear comfortable removable and
practically invisible
aligners to straighten your teeth and
now
people love their smile seriously like
they sent me these testimonials they're
real people with
um like their actual stories so justin
in georgia was like hey i used to have a
gap in my front the side and then
uh people were staring at my mouth all
the time and now canada was a perfect
company for me because you can't you
can't stop me from smiling now it's
pretty cool
how much a smile goes a long way um and
canon is a pretty awesome company they
basically pair you with a licensed
orthodontist who's an expert in tooth
movement and you have the same
orthodontist who created your plan
from start to finish so you never have
to wonder how you're doing you get
paired with one and it's just six months
you'll start
seeing results way before then and it's
thousands of dollars less
than traditional braces so here's the
deal become your best you
with your best smile start straightening
your teeth today
right now you can save 75 bucks on
candid starter kit go to candidco.com
yang and use the code yang that's
candidco.com
yang use the code yang take advantage of
this limited time offer and save 75
on your starter kit canon co
candidco.com
yang code yang
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a whole new emerging field of
positive education as well that has
various pillars
so if you tackle positive education is a
good tag line
just like positive psychology is a good
time like positive education because a
lot of education does seem kind of
negative right now
it really does which do you like better
humanistic education or positive
education
positive somehow
you know you're gonna be funny maybe
instead of humanistic you'd just be like
human
education like that
that actually makes me laugh but but
there there is something to that word
i mean i obviously love the word human
like you know again it was
like one of our main ideas but but to me
like human education
um like there is something inhuman about
our educational system right now i mean
that that is happening
well maybe we need a positive humanistic
education like let's get all the words
positive education is good because there
is also a sense that
our current educational system is a
little bit negative it's a little bit
like
uh you know conformist um
it's preparing kids for an economy that
really has not existed for decades and
you know like
there are other things like that that
you can look at about
our current system uh well it's
incredible you become like this champion
of
creativity imagination intuition
and it really is like at a whole
different axis than a lot of our current
um schools are teaching at so
what is that movement looking like like
what is that energy
so you've got like um uh seligman
and pen you've got like but like what
what does it look like writ large
and who are like the major figures in
addition to you
that are trying to push things in in a
more human direction so they have
big positive education conferences you
know with like thousand thousand people
from all over the world you know come to
these conferences
um but it you know if you if i can just
give some shout outs peggy kern over in
australia is
um leading the way of positive education
in australia um it's for some reason
england and australia in addition to the
us are the ones that are most um
interested in positive education and um
you know virtually all of australian
england
educators come to these conferences um
so it's really big over there
um but there are certain schools like
even in philadelphia a shipley school
is is leading the way um in terms of uh
the entire school is based on a positive
education model
so there are schools um that have this
so um
yeah and there i could name schools in
australia that are that are doing this
it's very interesting to me scott that
you cite international sources because
i have this sense that's been building
over the last number of years
that american culture and thus a lot of
our schools
are really really um mechanical
uh hyper competitive in a particular way
like it kind of built to like kind of
trying to
crush like a bunch of people through a
gate that can only accept
like like sub you know like uh like very
small proportion of them and that we're
all kind of trained this way that
there's like a real
um sort of competitive savagery to like
a lot of like the american
system uh and that extends from our
educational institutions to our economy
which now our economy is like the most
savage winner take all thing that you
know in human history
um uh at at this point um and so when
you talk about people who work on
positive education like you're like oh
the aussies
like the uk and i'm just like you know
come on america like we like america
genuinely needs like a massive
uh expansion of humanity i mean i it
that's so well put that i wanted you to
be president
again i'm just going to repeat that
again like
that would have been such a um amazing
uh
thank you i appreciate it yeah no but
the expansion of humanity is absolutely
what we need
but um if i may if i may just go even a
little bit further to more
concrete proposals because i really do
believe in bringing data
i believe in evidence i don't um i don't
want to make arguments you know if you
try to build
something on um on just ideology for
instance that's like building
something on uh you know a sand castle
you know like
you need it to have uh evidence based
just to a certain degree and you have to
be flexible to update the evidence
in light of new information um so
um i think that these following uh basic
human needs are things we need to learn
more in an education system and they
have a really strong
evidence-based and positive psychology
and humanistic ecology for them
so need for connection okay that's a big
one in our school system right now
um kids are uh profoundly lonely of
course right now being a virtual
that's even uh even worse and then so
you have a need for
uh safety and that can include you know
feeling as though your environment
is um that you've a secure attachment to
your environment you know attachment
theory comes into play here it's
important to have a secure attachment to
your not just your parents
but we don't often talk about the
necessity of having a secure attachment
to your teachers
you know like who's who's talking about
that you know
um and what that just means is that you
feel like you know they have your back
if you fail if you fall down
you know that you you can trust there's
trust in your environment we have a real
trust crisis right now in america with
each other the next one in my revised
hierarchy of needs is the need for
self-esteem but i specifically talk
about
healthy self-esteem versus narcissism we
do see a lot of
uh narcissism around you know um
in the in the current generation when i
say that the current generation of kids
get mad at me a lot of it's social media
man i mean
there's like a real you know i mean you
literally have numbers attached to how
many people
like you exactly
exactly but that's different so
narcissism is you know how
um do you think you're you're better
than others but just a healthy
self-esteem is that you just think
you're worthy
and i do think we have a um a crisis
of people feeling as though they're a
lot of people do not genuinely feel like
they are
are worthy and you know and you made the
argument in a scientific american
article that this is tied to
um the way we're treating people through
things like the economy or or the lack
of universal basic income
it was one of the points in my campaign
was like look if you had universal basic
income and then you could all look at
your
child and say uh your country loves you
your country values you and and you're
going to be all right and we're going to
invest in you
like you know and and as someone who's
run organizations i've made this
argument
um it's like you can always tell if an
organization is investing in you and if
it's not
it takes you approximately two days to
figure out if an organization
and and right sometimes yeah it's like
right by the second day you're like okay
like i see what's going on here and and
this is one reason why when
organizations put on these
frankly kind like sometimes uh sort of
like overdone or
ridiculous like trainings or boot camps
or in like uh
um rituals and whatnot um no matter how
like frankly like dumb it is um
it actually still shows like a form of
investment like they're trying they're
willing to like
spend company time like
you know like whatever the the training
rig moral is
that's actually a an excellent sign in
in the scheme of things um even though
some of those things are you know a
little
uh ham handed um so right now our
country
in my opinion um is not investing in
people
in a genuine way and people are kind of
picking up on it and then
i mean it's like like do you feel like
you are worth something
you know you can put on a brave face but
then like when you press on it like a
lot of people
you know are struggling with it i
couldn't agree more
i couldn't agree more um and we're not
uh we're not listening to each other's
uh suffering you know we're we're kind
of putting our own suffering in a lot of
ways as
uh and in a lot of ways we're not
realizing that a lot of other people
are really going through uh a lot of
this
same kind of suffering even if it takes
a different form yeah basic need
the basic need is unfulfilled and i
think you know it'd be wonderful if we
could rally
around the common humanity of the uh
basic needs that are being unfulfilled
versus um making everything into a
coalitional thing where
you know our suffering is is so
different you would never understand you
know
i mean i just want to move towards a
world where we we try to understand
at least well these are universal deeds
you've identified that it'd be very hard
for anyone to argue against it's like
look like shouldn't each of us
have uh you know like a feeling of
connectedness and safety and esteem
and so so the values you're identifying
right now
um are something of a recasting of
maslow's hierarchy of needs
in your latest book which i believe is
called transcend is that right
this book came out um fairly recently i
want to say just last year
oh well look look what i know well for
those of you who have the video that
there's a copy of like uh
the book what's this doing here what's
this doing here go ahead and read us the
subtitles scott
uh yeah it's the new science of
self-actualization the new science of
self-actualization so let's continue
past
uh the the need for esteem excellent
so first of all maslow never drew a
pyramid so that's a big misconception i
talk about in the book that uh p
everyone so you know everyone knows the
pier the pyramid with like wi-fi at the
bottom
or toilet paper at the bottom yeah
that's it's it's a meme
uh it turns out mazda never drew a
pyramid so i have a sailboat metaphor
so i argue that we have a boat uh that
needs to not have too many holes in
there so you don't go anywhere
but if you if you just have all your
holes you know uh if
you if you just have the boat secure
you're still not gonna go anywhere
unless you open up
the sails and and and and risk going
knowing that the winds could come
crashing down any time knowing that
um uh i don't know if that was right
metaphor wins i don't know if winds
crashed down but anyway you see what i'm
saying
um waves crashing down waves crashing
down winds
you still need to go in which is the
bottom of the boat is that
uh safety is that connectedness and
safety so the boat is
security and and the uh sale is
growth and the three needs that comprise
security are these are safety connection
and self-esteem so the ones we just
discussed was the boat like we already
all of the three of them are like the
hull of the boat i got it that's the
boat that's the boat okay
and if you can have those three needs
secure you feel like
you can start to explore the world in a
way that you feel vulnerable
yes i love it and this is one of the
arguments i was making which was like
look
like you can't get people concerned
about climate change if they can't put
food on their table that day
you know what i mean like and so so you
have to address like the
connectedness safety and esteem so what
does the mast look like
like how so if you open the sail yes if
you open the sail
so whereas the base of security is
safety the base
of the sail is exploration the need for
exploration
is a really deeply evolved need we share
with other animals but it takes unique
manifestations in humans because we can
bring in the intellect
we can bring in intellectual curiosity
that was another finding that i
that i that i found in my dissertation
research
was that intellectual curiosity was not
the same thing as iq um i found it was
only about a point five zero correlation
oh there
are some very uh bright people that are
totally in curious
not curious at all yes yes
not one iota not one iota um so
um being able to do what we call in our
research we call it cognitive
exploration
so you can have behavioral exploration
like you know like columbus set sail and
you know that's the physical
adventure seeking but you can also have
cognitive exploration like the human
imagination
you know like man alive is just like are
you reading books and stuff you know
what i mean but you talk about
the need to explore yeah exactly um so
that's the base and
and if you can go so when you open the
sale you are uh moving
with uh the spirit of exploration you're
not driven you're not driven by
fear anymore see this is the distinction
that maslow made
between deficiency motivation versus uh
growth motivation
wow when you have a deficiency
motivation everything in your life what
you're trying to do
is to make the world comport to your own
uh wow do we have a lot of deficiency
motivation
exactly we're living in a deficiency
motivated nation
that's correct yeah that's what what you
know the language i used on the campaign
was mindset of scarcity but it's it's
the same thing
same thing exactly exactly um so you
know
because when you're hungry right you're
saying feed me when you're when you're
profoundly uh lonely
you say you know like me when you don't
feel like you've respect then you start
saying respect me i deserve respect
but but all of that takes the flavor of
the deficiency realm of human existence
when you can get to the if you can get
to the being realm of human existence or
the growth realm and open up that sale
you are no longer driven um by
what you are deficient in you um uh
you're very forward-looking and you
you're driven by
a spirit of exploration of the unknown
and you're okay with the unknown but
most importantly you have what maslow
called
be love love for the being of others
it's it you could think of it maybe like
universal love but i've tried to make
the case in my book that
the need for connection is different
than be love
you can be very very connected to people
that
share similar political beliefs or
religious beliefs or in your in a group
and have a lot of hate for anyone that
you perceive to be in your out group but
when you have being love
you really have a deep abiding um love
for the being of
everyone that you meet there's kind of a
sacredness to the the uniqueness
so is is that the sale is that the fifth
thing after do you need to explore
yes yep that's exactly that's exactly
right so exploration and then
be love and then the third one is the
need for purpose
so i argue it's a whole system okay so
if you're driven
by a spirit of exploration you have a
humanitarian kind of loving sort of uh
orientation it's like look i you know
i'm i love people that
uh may disagree with me or like i don't
have certain things in common with
exactly and you have a sense of purpose
um so if from this sailing metaphor you
have a very clear vision of what island
where you're going where you're going
even though you might be very far away
from you're going and even though you
know
there's gonna be a lot of setbacks
there's gonna be like the the c is
unknown
you know like that's life folks i'm
sorry to like
tell you that santa claus doesn't exist
you know in a sense say like you know
wife there's going to be a lot of
unknowns and
and but you still have to go you still
have to move so
so one side of the ledger is deficiency
motivation the other one is growth
motivation is that right
growth or massive called it um the being
realm of human existence sometimes
he uses those two the b realm the b
realm
so i think most people listening to this
can easily understand and relate to uh
the need for connectedness
connectedness safety and esteem uh you
know if those
those things aren't present then it's
very very difficult to
feel like you know you you can um make
positive things happen
or even that you know you deserve things
like you you know do deserve a thousand
bucks a month i mean that you know
um uh and then the the higher order
needs are around the ability to explore
to love people that aren't like you
necessarily
and then have a purpose and
uh you know if you ask many people i
think you know like what is your purpose
they'll look at you like you know like
like it's a very very odd question
frankly um and i think there are a lot
of people that think
like even trying to ascertain your
purpose is like a very privileged
pursuit because
at that point it must be that your other
needs are being met um
and this is all tied together where
there are so many americans who are
struggling right now in ways big and
small that
you know it's like like trying to have
someone trying to address some of these
higher questions
a lot of them aren't in position to be
able to
consider them very rightfully so you
know and it's one reason why
as a society we have to do a much better
job of
trying to address people's sense of
safety and connectedness and esteem
from day one and i think our schools
are not doing a good job of those things
it's not just schools i mean the fact is
like one of the things i said
on the campaign trail is that schools
control about 35 of our kids educational
outcomes and then the other two thirds
are
family environments um income level
unfortunately type of neighborhood
number of words read to them when
they're a child stress levels in the
household like
all of these things um and so we're
holding our
schools in some ways to an impossible
standard because you know if like a
kid's going home to an environment where
they're not gonna be able to learn it's
like well
like or in this case you know maybe they
haven't been in school for a year you
know like and so they're going to show
up and you know it's like their their
ability to
catch up is going going to be
more constrained or diminished but this
is an incredible
framework um and it's something that i
think
uh most everyone can understand and
would agree with
and it kind of builds on and adapts
maslow's work
in a way that's i think
um very directed and and actually more
practical in a way because like i think
we've all heard maslow's
uh hierarchy of needs and then you're
like all right like
see the pyramid whereas i feel like your
work
is a little bit more instructive like it
moves us in a direction
um and and these are the ideas um from
your book transcend the new science of
self-actualization that's right yeah
that's right
um and has the response to this book
been uh but probably i'm sure it has
been i'm sure a lot of people are
excited about it
yeah i'm really really pleased at the
reception in the field of psychology
um uh just almost
uh just universal uh kind of is that
that seems very modest to say that
universal praise um but um
but it's like if that's but like i don't
know how to say it in
in a way that i that i don't people like
i've just been very very pleased the
reception um aaron beck who
um the founder of cognitive behavioral
therapy he's 98
he's 99 years old and he wrote a blurb
he said this is a significant advance in
psychology
and so that was a wow such high praise
that must have been so meaningful to you
that was like i was in tears you know
yeah yeah
that must have really given you some uh
bee love
yes yes yes you're fulfilling your
purpose scott
um i mean you really are fulfilling your
purpose it's actually
so are you like tremendous to see and i
think when someone
when someone's doing the kind of work
that you can feel like comes from a very
deep place within them and it's
happening like people do sense it i
think it's one reason why people are
drawn to you i mean you're doing what
you're meant to do for sure
and you're making such incredible
contributions
if someone wants to keep up with you
support your work find out more
about your ideas like how how can they
follow you or get in touch
oh thanks andrew my webpage
scottberrykaufman.com
i have kind of everything everything
there so my podcast i host the
psychology podcast which
um all the episodes can be found on
there and i have free i've resources
section
um you know if you're a parent you're a
teacher or you're just a
you're an adult and you want to
self-actualize i have lots of free
resources so i kind of put everything
there on my my web page
i also have on there some tests
self-actualization tests i developed and
scientifically validated
they can tell you um what your main
sources of self-actualization are but i
also have a test
that tells you where you are on the dark
side or the light side of the star wars
force
it actually is a scientifically
validated test that can kind of
tell you you know if you need to work a
little more on okay people
i know you don't like tests but you know
what you love you love those quizzes
that tell you fun things about yourself
um so head head to scott's website
to find out how light or dark your force
is um and where you are
in terms of self-actualization i think
you're going to get a lot of takers man
from this uh recording because who does
not want to know
how self-actualized they are i'm so glad
we finally got to connect scott
uh you're a force for humanity uh and
i'm
thrilled um to have someone like you
fighting for the positive changes that
so many of us
know we need in the world um yeah
consider me a friend and ally and
um hopefully we will have more people
see how important your work is
and then most importantly actually make
the changes necessary in the real world
to be able to prepare
our kids and our people for what's to
come
thank you that means a lot to me it was
so fun talking to you today
you